people don't have enough rules in their  life for themselves so for instance i  get out of bed in 10 minutes or less  doesn't matter  and i don't want to that's why i have  the rule because i went to callus your  mind literally i went through a period  where i would lay in bed for three to  four hours awash in shame and my  inability to get out of bed and it just  embarrassed me and so i felt badly about  myself so i wanted to make a change so i  knew that i needed a bright line so  bright line 10 minutes or less you get  out of bed as soon as you realize you're  awake that's it so and the rule is more  specific it's like i have to have had at  least five hours of sleep  but once you put the rule in place then  you just live by it and that's how you  earn credibility